alors je me regarde je veux faire une
interview spéciale pour vous qui
s'appelle l'interview sans intérêt ça
c'est cool
[Applaudissements]
on les bouge pas pendant le génial
vous savez bien mais pas bougé mois on
n'a pas bougé serge by me espion à une
question chacun de l'interview sans
intérêt tout commence avec vous cadre
est ce que vous savez coudre
intéressant voyez avec les pieds
seulement bien
olivier vous préférez la mer ou la
montagne
difficile comme question prendre le
temps de répondre
la montagne la mental
cad est ce qu'elle nous a rappelé qu'
est-ce que vous aimiez les cols
difficiles et qu'on question
la montagne
à la montagne mais est ce que cannes est
ce que vous avez dit balle pour lui
kabila
n'a pas vraiment faux julian si je dis
bah ouais c'est l'un des méchants
d'intérêt profiter mes poches parce que
sinon vous allez avoir des petites
surprises au format 100 g sur moi dont
on n'est pas chez comédie là j'ai pas
dis bah vous avez pas dit balle pour le
caddie vous avez vu les résultats du
référendum c'est incroyable oh la la
c'est l'interdiction
évidemment
ma voiture
je
n'ai pas de voiture bon c'est très bonne
règle et c'est des trucs en même temps
je teste
cas de vous y croyez à ce truc vous
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu